[Musique]
j'ai des courbatures
on évalue et 3 heures du matin moi
j'aimais je les fais c'est tout à
l'heure à laquelle je me couche en fait
tous les âges et maintenant c'est la
formule 1
avec un homme dis donc ça va cogner
comme cinquième jour de marché réveil de
plomb pour nos dix huit marcheurs ils
sont sur le point d'attaquer le dernier
tiers du parcours le tir le plus
sélectif puisqu'il entre le domaine de
la rosa
l'avenir appartient bon froid s'est
porté sur la voiture de turcs manger le
matin alors pardon comme angèle est ok
mais là j'ai fait j'ai mangé de graines
comme un cheval topo du jour je sais
juste derrière juste sur la terre c'est
un été très simple une longue ligne
droite de la cabane de chanrion en
direction de la cabane d'eric la cabane
bertholle est au programme du long pour
monique juriste à la retraite c'est la
journée de la dernière
la veille elle obtenu au sujet de son
mas quelque chose et c'est dès le départ
qu'elle devra s'il est d'un seul de la
cadence et tenir le choc pendant sept
heures sur l'interminable classiers le
témoin
je sais quand je veux je peux mais
est-ce que corps va être d'accord ça je
sais pas nature dort encore ça c'est le
grand moment qu'ils ont partir le matin
tôt avec notre petite lampe
on se retourne on voit tous ces petits
lucioles j'en ai rêvé depuis longtemps
[Musique]
vous voyez qu'elle trouve ça super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai découvert
la beauté de la glace avec le soleil
c'était comme un tapis de diamant et
puis on a un horizon
on est dans du blanc dans un désert
blanc ça c'est fabuleux
je m'y attendais à ses paysages mais
vraiment subjugué par fonçant sur notre
planète web décorer le bac il est
lunaire c'est qu'il est vraiment extra
terrestres et à cette montagne immense
et puis moi je suis tout petit quoi
c'est quand même toujours dans le
questionnement tu dis mais attend
comment ça se fait qu'il ya des shows
aussi brutale à la fois par le climat si
belle qui a décidé que ce serait
organisée de telle sorte c'est un peu ça
le côté mystique
[Musique]
moula ça ça fait l'amour
une baie d'hyères
alors ça ça isabelle ce qui est
intéressant c'est que si tu vas y tire
dessus tu va visiter le trou un peu plus
voir ça s'est un peu moins intéressant
d'accord tout ça j'en suis là on va
d'ailleurs quelqu'un qui tombe ça vient
de casser ou sinon ça doit être des
autres
[Musique]
section les airs magique
il ya les physiciens il ya des
physiciens qui calcule le temps de jeu
depuis le bruit
ça donne un peu l'idée de l'épaisseur de
la glace ici et c'est en train de bouger
d'ailleurs
mais ce sont de bons gars les joues sera
irrigué août soit son gain j'ai ballon
clés et j'ai plus de campi d'accord les
voir marie pour aller là par messi et
wayne morale légale morale c'est pénible
à la corde en possession c'est difficile
de s'adapter au rythme des sports
c'est le dernier quart d'heure cette
ballerine de l'opéra alex changement
viendrait presque à regretter cette voie
là bas il prend la mire et rick nash a
sonné sa psy ni l'autre trop bien un
pyromane moi non mais très loin caméra à
sa mine et chercher une bouteille de sa
compagne
monique joue décidément de malchance
elle ne lutte plus contre la fatigue
elle lutte désormais contre la douleur
une demi heure plus tôt la doyenne de
pau a chuté sur une plaque de glace
ouais
ah ouais l'excès parce qu'au bout de ses
peines ça a super bien marché
aujourd'hui d'appeler ses engagements
d'hier
[Applaudissements]
ou pas j'ai mal ah bah non tamalous la
tonne atteint chauvin c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon fit le caillou projet
la chance qu'ils ont
oui super enfin tout ça génial
iata qui liera le dernier bon un petit
pot 1 ont de la mémoire vous êtes posé
nos valises que refuge vous
tu vois
[Musique]
bien joué monique extra ça va aller ce
coude
vous avez un peu l'évolution dans la
journée ouais tu sais pas tout ils
étaient encordés pour que tout se passe
est sûre je suis partie commis plus
tellement légère mais surtout je me suis
froid s'est entiché d'une mousse hamad
ça fait mal quand tu respires wii la wii
écoute c'est normal cela t'a le losc y
passe
je pense que tu l'a tapé fort
celle-là oui oui oui la région non mais
que ça soit moi qui ai même eu la poisse
à me surprend pas du tout et ça
surprendrait personne de mon entourage
quand il ya un pépin tout le monde rit
sur maps atteint alors ça attire la
guigne c'est possible
zuma ce nombre la douleur non c'est vrai
ces passages à son fiston
[Musique]
c'est marrant au début je me disais huit
jours ça va être long en faire
maintenant c'est que huit jours lire une
semaine de parisiens quoi et puis là en
fait j'ai peut-être pour la première
fois perçu l'instant présent je crois
que là il ya une espèce de dimension
spirituelle
un truc comme ça m'a mené au foreing du
chaos
comme un pantin désarticulé
et j'en ai une deuxième qui va commencer
donc là je les ai bien prévu et je me
suis renforcé le talent de droit pour ne
pas avoir de problème demain je me suis
dit la montagne est imperturbable
elle est majestueuse et les puissants
mais elle te cerne bien dans la mesure
où j'ai eu cet handicap et que ça m'a
fait freiné aussi dans mes élans et elle
m'a projet
[Musique]
oui
j'ai un look de sacs poubelles j'ai vu
mais celui-là même à paris on n'a pas
encore osé
j'aime bien ces conditions faire ça
c'est plus l'aventurier quand même
c
[Musique]
c'est une idée nouvelle trois mois
tout le monde n'est pas à l'appel on
n'est qu'à passer une mauvaise nuit et
et
c'est providentiel ce truc à je suis
très contente je ris intérieurement
parce qu'au fond abandonné sur lésions
corporelles légère c'est beaucoup plus
glorieux que grand maman qui s'effondre
c'est pas brillant
c'est arrivé j'ai atteint mon but
raisonnable
[Musique]
c'est déjà nés en hélicoptère on
pourrait payer que je serais pas allé
tellement j'ai la trouille mais voilà si
vous n'avez pas au fait comme lopy de
tout fermer les yeux
[Musique]
oui
si pour monique c'est la fin de
l'aventuré les glissières rescapés de la
haute route contenant leur bonheur
au programme de la matinée un joli
plongeon dans la vallée 1300 mètres fut
la future de munich sous forme de mise
en jambes il faut sérieuse mais ils ne
le savent pas c'est pour cet après midi
les rares
tu sois pas précisé mais tu es jeune tu
as plus les matches
[Applaudissements]
faux
nos marcheurs attaque la montée de la
cabane d'ayrton légendaire dit d'aigle
perché 1300 mètres ou une montre
redoutable autant que redouté y compris
par les randonneurs les plus avertis
bertholle c'est comme un grand cru
ça se mérite
[Musique]
or dans ces moments là même question de
solidarité c'est le règne du chacun pour
soi tout le monde puise dans ses
réserves
que réserve mandales autant que physique
on s'approche c'est donc un marché déjà
recouru à bon compte
je compliquer le maître pour savoir que
c'est encore loin mais je voyais arriver
je sais c'est juste que frau faut que je
me pousse au derrière que le sac est
lourd ce but on me laure mais là faut
que ça se passe là la manière ouais par
avance et des gens avec ce qu'ils
gardent les deux oreilles synchro un
gros bâton stack manic la québécoise on
n'est pas la seule à carburer désormais
mentale et dernières ressources avant la
panne sèche
[Musique]
côté souffle ça sent quand tu peux pas
c'est un truc qui tue
à monique burg ouais ça va d'une gravure
et les tests teddy je veux maigrir des
fesses pendant ses séjours il ya aussi
l'altitude
je parlais predict musique moi c'est
pareil mais devenir impressionnant
[Musique]
quelle altitude dans la cité aux sept
familles site est notée au tu fais à 120
demain 3007 à la tête blanche
aujourd'hui 3003 a été folle alors
aujourd'hui insulaires comme tel et
comme un jeu toujours plus vite
oui c'est toujours mieux en mieux moins
en moins fatigués ouais non comme un
jeune de vata l'avait fait une bonne
montée
je vous félicite d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être toi qui même mieux
on sera pas et moi j'ai découvert qu
avec monique si je me passe un mètre dix
mètres est la valentine ralenti je suis
obligé de pour faire appel comme la
tienne à monique monique ça me rappelle
quelque chose
j'en avais une toi mais juste un petit
mot là toute l'équipe plat pour les
nouvelles de monique comme vous le savez
des partis ce matin des vignettes dans
un magnifique oiseau c'est le vol lui a
sûrement plus sachez quand même qu'elle
avait trois côtes cassées
donc ce n'était pas du chichi à voilà
et puis elle va bien elle se repose à
l'hôpital nord et chaleur de la plaine
elles vous elle vous embrasse tous allez
allez la mode ou services en maître
c'est exactement
l'un des médecins m est ce qu'un vide de
sens il faut viser la vie
[Musique]
faut-il s'entendre
la notion toute relative des pires
ce sera la septième tour de marche il
faudra grimper jusqu'à 3700 m
dans déjà croire que le pari est gagné
mais si le moral est en hausse les
réserves sont en tennis
et les réserves il en faudra pour
affronter les deux derniers jours
zermatt est certes à bout touchant mais
il faudra passer par tête blanche le
point culminant de la autre petite larme
pour les un gros souci pour les autres
avant de se frayer un chemin à travers
un labyrinthe de province sans oublier
de fêter dignement le doyen la course 75
ans et de l'énergie à revendre
[Musique]